non
en alberta le boeuf est roi la province
est de loin le chef de file de la
production bovine au canada et à l'anc
animal de wesley et une heure au nord de
nantes une personne n'a oublié crise de
la vache folle windhoek afp
je me souviens très bien de cette
période chaotique au moment où il
débutait à peine sa carrière d'éleveurs
s'il a pu reprendre la ferme familiale
d'autres jeunes producteurs comme lui à
l'époque n'ont pas eu cette chance
emporté par la crise et la chute
dramatique des prix la vache folle a
fait perdre entre 6 et 10 milliards de
dollars à l'industrie
les producteurs à liberté se sont
relevés de la crise maisons subissent
encore des années plus tard les
conséquences
[Musique]
l'encéphalopathie spongiforme bovine est
une maladie neurologique qui se transmet
par consommation de viande ou de résidus
animaux contaminés de stribe of this is
fait ici surtout une maladie fatale pour
laquelle aucune guérison possible
rappelle le docteur herman schaetzel
l'université de calgary
ce mythe et mondial en la matière il a
étudié pendant toute sa carrière la
maladie de la vache folle
le canada avait beau avoir béni dès 1997
les et didier fabre d'animaux dans
l'alimentation bovine une première vache
infectées par la maladie détectée en
alberta le 20 mai 2003 même si cette
année s'était écoulé le professeur je ne
crois que les autorités canadiennes
étaient mal préparés pour affronter la
crise et à la ministre fédérale de
l'agriculture dans le gouvernement
chrétien
il admet aujourd'hui que le premier cas
de transmission de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique n'a pas particulièrement
alerté les autorités canadiennes en 1985
rapidement c'est la paix n'est qu'après
la découverte du premier cas les états
unis annonce aussitôt qu'il stoppe
l'importation de boeuf canadien
la secrétaire américaine à la grille
culture ne prend même pas la peine
d'avertir son homologue canadien
dans les mois qui suivent c'est toute la
classe politique canadienne qui se
mobilisent pour venir à la rescousse du
boeuf canadien après d'intenses efforts
de dépistage et l'abattage de plus de
3000 bêtes les marchés d'exportation
recommencent à acheter du boeuf canadien
petit à petit à l'automne 2003 la crise
a causé d'énormes tort mais elle a aussi
eu des effets positifs reconnaît ce qui
était au coeur de la tempête
25 ans plus tard une autre crise
sanitaire secoue la planète
est-ce que des leçons de la vache folle
aurait pu servir à atténuer les effets
de la pandémie kovy 19
herman schaetzel en est convaincu même
si leur gravité n'est pas du tout la
même
les deux infections aurait pu être
évitée si la santé de l'environnement
des animaux étaient mieux protéger le
professeur schaetzel évoque le concept
de santé globale où les humains
finissent par souffrir des problèmes qui
affectent l'environnement et les animaux
animal de 6
si tout le monde souhaite un retour à la
normale
lalbenque lives espère lui aussi que des
leçons que 8,19 ne sont pas oubliés
haoues la clé comparaison entre les deux
crises se font naturellement
après la vache folle la kfw doha elle
aussi mise à l'épreuve la résilience des
producteurs mais aussi bien se préparer
après avoir appris et précédent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]